so uh changing topics I went to Hakuna
again yesterday it's been a while I've
been talking eh
um and uh for the first time I actually
like I guess explored some of the more
like let's say touristy areas of hakone
the pirate ship I did not go I I've
heard about this pirate ship no we uh we
went up to the mountain and like it just
it just reminded me how far like
Japanese like how far Japanese areas
will push this one little thing as like
a selling point for like tourism I am
talking about the black egg man
oh it's a [__] okay so like we got a hug
in it I'm in Sydney so we're taking like
our friend Eugene there and me and City
are very much just yo we just want to go
and just chill out and just go to the
Onsen and chill out on Eugene's like no
we I want to explore I've heard this
thing called this like black egg that
gives you like good elf and you have to
travel up this [__] Mountain to get
there
um
it's like it's like it is the shittiest
side quest ever so we we go up there and
we're like um
and uh it takes like [__] took us
like 45 minutes to get to get up this
mountain with all like the because how
can I even though it's like a touristy
area if you don't have a car it's still
it's pretty hard to get around yeah
because there are no there's like
limited taxis in the area it's a very
kind of hilly area so what most people
know what most tourists do is they hire
they go to there they go to their Onsen
and then they just stay right and then
they just stay in that Onsen for their
entire duration and just relax uh so
actually like getting around to
different uh different spots is a pretty
you know pretty hard so to get up to
this uh to get up to this mountain
uh to where like I guess there are kind
of like G um geothermal activity
um The sulfur Lakes yeah it's like
sulfur lakes and stuff like that which
is
it's it's fine so I don't know if you
ever wanted to go to a mountain that
smells like farts perpetually it's it's
just like it's a place to go it's it's
literally like going there you're like
oh I'm I'm smelling Satan's ass right
now
this is what Satan's ass smells like and
I'm like cool let's uh let's try this
black egg that uh Eugene has uh
excitedly like been talking about for
the past 45 [__] minutes because I
just want to go back to this Onsen
um and so we go there and we thought I
thought it would just be like one small
shack or something that's up there no
they have like this entire complex with
just it it's it's like a it's like a
two-story massive like shopping center
based around this black [__] egg I'm
like what the [__] it's a black egg like
that that is like that place is the
epitome of milking the cow drink they
have they had a entire [__] Museum
there like what are you why is this here
and in all honestly like when you
actually find out about how they make
the black eggs it's really not that
impressive all they do is they get an
egg and they throw it into a boiling
sulfapon for like three minutes and then
that's and then some chemical reaction
turns the shell black when you crack
open the egg though it just looks like
an egg oh it yeah it looks kind of like
weird because you know you see the egg
and it's like warm and it's black but
I'm like you could have just put this in
[__] food coloring I wouldn't be able
to tell the difference
um and also the egg kind of smells like
fast because of the salt yeah and the
Egg kind of smells like farts so yeah
you crack it open and it's it's just a
normal boiled egg yeah I remember eating
it Eugene's like I can really like taste
the sulfur and I I took I took a bite
and I'm like this is this is like every
other building it is a hard-boiled egg
I'm like bro this needs some salt in it
man like you literally paid like what
you the amount you'd pay for like a full
pack of 12 eggs yeah one black egg and
I'm like the line to just get these eggs
was like it was the entire like length
of the shop I'm like I'm like the
Japanese are a [__] Master at
marketing the stupidest [__] thing
yeah people will travel to your
prefecture to do uh the one thing though
that's cool up there I don't know if
they still have it but they have like a
an ice cream place like a soft serve
place oh that does black soft serves but
it's all it is it looks cool because
it's like it's this pitch black ice
cream
it's just vanilla ice cream
yeah they normally put charcoal on it
yeah they put charcoal in it yeah but
when you eat it it's just a vanilla
chocolate vanilla's actually pretty good
though huh charcoal vanilla is pretty
good chocolate vanilla is good but is it
worth spending 45 minutes to go up a
mountain that smells like Foss to get it
yeah not sure you ever do that [__]
where you put like charcoal on your
teeth
yes
I used to use like a chocolate Face Wash
yeah yeah I don't I feel like it doesn't
work it got rid of my acne oh okay yeah
part of the problem with a lot of these
like let's say
like self-grooming self-like
um likes beauty tips and stuff like that
is I don't know who to [__] trust
because let's let's be honest like I
like basically all of these products are
made in a lab right yeah with some
chemicals that you'd hope help whatever
the [__] they're selling but like every
every time I like go on YouTube or go on
the internet to like search up how do I
get rid of let's say I have like a bad
acne day or something what's the best
way to like get rid of that yeah a lot
of the time it's like
a lot of the time a lot of stuff like
that'll be like hey uh maybe you should
sleep more exercise and eat healthy and
then like no no no I didn't come for
that answer yeah like just you know
stand in the sunlight for a little bit
and uh go away well I I started wearing
uh
uh every morning uh for I was using face
mask for a while and I kind of like it
but it's also kind of annoying so you
have to leave them on for like 15
minutes yeah sometimes I just want to
get into streaming right away yeah and
then um I know that a lot of people said
wear sunscreen every day yeah so I
started doing that and I don't know if
it's gonna be I think yeah what is the
science of that well so so obviously
like even when it's like cloudy and
stuff there's UV and the UV UV is pretty
bad for your skin in general so the idea
is that if you're just always wearing
and it's a moisturizing cream and
sunscreen and yeah so hopefully the idea
is like I get moisturize and also
protect from UVS because who's getting
sunburned in his house well you know I
mean
even if I'm walking outside for like an
hour I'm like I'm putting it on that's
why you don't use light mode
[Applause]
I think UV is what like kind of Ages
your skin like yeah oh yeah tremendous
speed it up so yeah yeah yeah even I was
thinking about Ludwig he was like it was
like a cloudy day and he was like I'll
check the UVS I'm like what yeah show
the uv's outside I'm like why he's like
gotta see if I could have put sunscreen
have you have you ever you know those
like strips those like black strips that
you see like on your nose that like gets
rid of like yeah you know have you ever
used them yeah I've used it have you
ever seen it be as effective as what
those YouTube videos make it seem like I
feel like it works but not well enough
to make me want to keep doing it yeah
like I I've seen videos especially the
videos where you know the advertising of
course of course because of course it's
gonna be the videos they advertise and
it looks so [__] satisfying just
seeing like the little pins like pop out
as you as you peel it but what is this
used for uh getting rid of blackheads
like on your nose and stuff like that
um but every time I've seen someone do
it I swear to God it just rips out their
hair I don't know I don't know I I never
see any [__] blackheads on but
they're just waxing their face I don't
know I did it I saw blackheads but I I
found that the results were so subpar
yeah I was like I don't I don't even
know I had these like I couldn't even
tell right I never the noise I did it is
because they marked it towards me and
made me think that I had a problem and
so I did it and I was like when I guess
there's something on it but I'm like I
don't really see a difference I feel a
difference but that's just because I
peeled my skin yeah yeah so I feel I
feel different no matter what when I do
that yeah right I don't know maybe